dan is fantastic to have you here at
London Film and Comic Con today what are
you enjoying so far about the event yeah
it's it's been great so far I've just
been a Crouch it's it's huge there are
so many people and they're all very
pleased to see me which is very nice and
we've just had a panel as well which has
been great talking about Doctor Who old
and new so it's a yeah it's been great
fun what is the kind of questions that
people been asking you today well lots
of people who people have asked me as to
whether or not the character I play
Strax and master and Jenny I don't have
their own spin-off series to which I
replied I don't know but I think it will
be a pretty decent idea but we shall
have to see how would you like to see
that happen I mean what would you like
to be doing in the spin-off oh gosh I
mean I think the further adventures of
vastra Jenny and Strax in Victorian
London and the environments like solving
crimes and sort of her yeah doing
exciting things I'm liking the idea
let's make it happen yes a lahar see
I'll see what I can do do you enjoy
particularly about being part of the
Doctor Who universe
oh it's firm you know watch the program
lows when I was a child you know I was a
huge shoot family and so just being part
of it now is just great because I can
see how people engage with it so nicely
and it's a great program as it can
select go a new arrogance of like it can
be everything even though our characters
are ostensibly based on the lighting
century now it doesn't mean that we
can't go to space and do all sorts of
exciting things and I get to do stunts
which is amazing you know you know I
burst through a window in the last
series and sort of sort of jumped down
on a cherry picker as well as a from one
point so yeah it's it's it's enormous
fun very very cool I mean what do you
enjoy about stratasys great character
great looking character as well you know
he looks fantastic
which shall have the wonderful people of
millenia effects thankful but it's it's
he's great combination of bizarrely for
a Sontaran he's essentially well-meaning
but still psychotic and violent so it's
there's a lot of humor to be mined land
a fact that he takes himself so very
very seriously and nobody else does
which has always been part of the
Sontarans makeup in a certain way but
perhaps not exploited quite so much as
now but yeah he's great from
what do you think about the doctors that
you've worked with who you enjoyed
working in meticulous oh well I didn't
actually get a chance to work with David
that much I only had one scene with him
where he knocked me out with a mallet
and I fell over so I was difficult to
get the rub
but Matt's Matt's fantastic I mean he
sort of he's just got so much energy and
so much he's always on it in terms of
his performance and yeah he just gives
loads of different interpretations of it
as well for different takes and it's
just great watching him work and sort of
that of course obviously he's leaving
now that there's all the speculation
who's gonna be the next Doctor Who would
you put your money on who would you like
to see is a next Doctor III really don't
know I mean I like to be surprised
really I think it's got to be a good
actor oh good - whose whose whose worth
their salt but just someone who doesn't
come with any baggage a mysterious man
who comes along and amazes us it's been
talked also is it time to have a
different kind of doctor may be a woman
or and it's someone who's a bit
different than the ones we've seen in
the past what's your take on yeah I mean
I think I think the program is always
flexible enough to accommodate it's like
a different interpretation of the lead
character I mean there are essential
qualities that make him the doctor but
but yeah I mean anything's like more
left fields I think will be very
interesting when you're a kid and you're
watching Doctor Who what did you enjoy
particular about the show and here were
the doctors he's got all in there
brilliant when I was a kid when I first
started watching it was a very end of
Tom Baker but then Peter Davison were
suppose was kind of my doctor and then
it was when I was about five or six
years old it was absolutely real I
didn't know anything else about him it
was just amazing and then was a little
bit older I knew a bit more about it was
a bit more of a connoisseur and
Sylvester McCoy oh so oh yes I can I can
see what you're doing there that's very
clever in Mike's of 12 year old way but
yeah I think it's that a combination of
sly character whose mysterious it's
great now that we've you know at some
point you know we kind of knew so much
about the doctor and we've been to
California injected in him as well yeah
it's a lovely carrot a fiftieth year is
well it's hard to believe it's
incredible isn't it it's just quite
terrifying I remember watching the
twentieth anniversary and I was a kid
and now it's quietly I feel old which is
which is not a feeling which I'm
particularly enjoying but you like to
see happen in that anniversaries first
time she knows sure it's gonna be
amazing
oh gosh I don't I don't know I'm just
waiting to be surprised I mean with the
name of the doctor at the end of that
sometimes we don't get the end of the
scripts before they're actually shot so
I was watching it at home and then John
Hurt came on the screen and that was its
John hood that's amazing so it's just a
nice feeling even though I'm part of it
I should be surprised by as well still
be surprised even that you have been
polysphere it's a really lovely feeling
I guess yeah absolutely no and it's it's
you you still have that enthusiasm for
it it's it's about
you'd like to come back as Strax yeah I
think the worlds is you could do with
more Strax at some point but we'll have
to see I'm sure I'm sure we haven't seen
the last minute how would you like to
see him return how do you we can see his
big comeback
yeah something where I'm on Peter Pan
wires being raised down from the ceiling
in a big select cloud of dry ice yes the
eighties music video
what do you think about you know Doctor
Who now we've had of course when it came
back Christopher Eccleston David Tennant
Matt Smith of course now and who knows
in the future and how do you feel it
compares to sort of the Doctor Who at
the pass
oh I mean I think it's I think it's
respectful of the Doctor Who the past
but it doesn't it's not completely
constrained by it and I think they were
very astute in the way that when they
brought it back they didn't come with
bags and bags of continuity so I'm going
here is he got some garlic Freitas
thirty-three generations they didn't
they weren't overly hurried to actually
introduce all that backstory but I think
as the audience have grown more familiar
with the new series and they've been
able to reintroduce it in a nice sort of
you know nice tasteful way so obviously
having the Daleks back in the first
series that makes sense but other than
that the fact that he's a mysterious
traveler in a box who can travel in time
it's that's all you need really in a
funny kind of way it's more powerful
threat to be slowly revealed and sorry
and also for the long-term fans as well
actually the first time when he says I'm
from Gallifrey and then you serious like
it's nice how it sort of them yeah it's
lots of slow-burning little things what
was it like being so direct it takes up
a hill it's it's it's it's it's a good
stuff like two and a half hours or so to
get into the makeup to have that to be
glued on to my face and then there's
some costume as well takes a bit of
getting into and yeah I mean it's it's
it's a it can be a long day in in the
suit but you know ultimately it's wrong
as a rewarding one but you know
everyone's very respectful of Dan
probably needs to sit down now just
because if you do to here you did you do
tire out quite quickly just being in the
kind of rubber suit and the gun is
amazingly heavy as well it's made of
metal so and the fact is it because my
arms have got my Popeye arms have got
sort of rubber on them it means that
slimed weight lifting the weight
doubling so by the end of it I could be
yeah I'm not quite as strong as
commander Strax exactly super if you are
we're very appreciative of that as well
and finally what do you like to say to
Doctor Who fans out there keep watching
happy 50th
you